[Applause]
we wanted to keep it quiet i don't want
to scare the crocodiles
i'm gonna go feed a crocodile right now
this could get interesting
i love you
[Music]
what is up everybody chris as well as
the pond guy
we are here at the alligator farm in
saint augustine florida for the winter
retreat and we are
rocking and rolling full of energy today
well you you definitely are
i'm excited because we have a lot of
newbies and so a lot of newbies are
going to be with you
and a lot of the advanced guys are going
to be over with ed at the other project
so we got two projects going on this is
my first time here what a beautiful
place i talked to john the director last
night he said this is one of the third
oldest zoos in the entire country so
we're gonna have a lot of fun today and
we're gonna start them on live in the
aquascape lifestyle i love it
that's fine holy cow so as greg said we
are here taking over the alligator farm
today i am standing in front of what is
going to be the job site for
the 8x11 pond with about a six seven
foot stream on it this is where the
ecosystem pond is going to be installed
this will be a
bird enclosure so we're gonna have
waterfalls back
up over there meandering little stream
maybe we'll include some driftwood
elements for them to perch up on
but just like shallow pools slow moving
water that kind of stuff and then the
pond will sit over in here skimmer over
on this side this is going to be a
training exercise
for a lot of newbies so what i love
about events like this
is yes we have the advanced build upon
which ed is leading oh look at my hair
the bonds but um what i love about this
is ed is of course leading the advanced
build but today we
are doing a just a standard 8 by 11
ecosystem pond and the simplicity of it
the 20 products in 20 steps and that's
what we're going to achieve
so the whole part of the point of this
yes is to build an
incredible beautiful enclosure bird
loving stream that's visually
amazing but the more important thing is
to educate our customers the contractors
and
some of the people that are actually
do-it-yourselfers on how to efficiently
put in a pond and do it profitably so we
want to teach them the right way so that
they can avoid all the pitfalls that we
learned over the years so the point of
this
space back here is to show them the
basic math or arithmetic or just a basic
level of water features so i've got some
incredible
cacs that are also going to be with me
i've got jay duke over here
river cross hey mark how are you feeling
today huh how you doing today give me
this thing
good morning good morning it's a nice
chilly morning but it's going to be a
beautiful day for a build a pond day
so how many people do we have at their
first ever build upon day show hands
yeah look at that wow that's awesome
that is terrific these build upon days
are a hands-on experience
we want to encourage everybody to jump
in and get involved and talk which i
don't think is going to be a problem
with this group
we seem to have a very energetic group
which i'm completely loving we've got mr
chris hanson that's going to lead this
build i'm just kicking it off and
saying hi to everybody and answering any
questions and what i love about chris
this is what he does this is his job out
there doing this every single day so i'm
going to let chris hansen tell you why
he changed it from there and there and a
little bit of explanation how the day's
going to go
chris hansen everybody first of all
thank you
everybody for being here like i said
yesterday under the tent i'm so excited
and i just
i love this this this really gets me
going and this is why
i do what i do is to i love seeing all
the fresh faces i love seeing people
that i know and have
deep friendships with like greg said
lean into these guys that have been
doing it a while
they are invaluable resources not just
myself or greg please
network with these people that have been
around the block they know what the hell
they're doing they're going to help you
avoid a lot of the pitfalls just don't
be afraid to ask
[Music]
okay so it is 9 30 in the morning we're
a little behind but not because of
anything besides talking but
we're doing this 20 products 20 steps so
the pond is marked out
skimmer's on one side bio falls is on
the other we're putting the pipe down
and once the pipe is down we're going to
start digging the pond out
great group
so that right there is a typical
filtration system that you will see
there's a swimming pool filter that is
filtering
there's a swimming pool filter which you
see all the time that is filtering
a pond versus a swimming pool
first digging going on right now
[Music]
we got some young guys here let's chip
that out we've got a slab of concrete
underneath there
sidewalk
[Music]
we've got jay and tim over here kind of
explaining some of the next steps we've
got the underlayment in
now what we're going to do is we are
going to get that epdm liner
we've got jackson sammy over here we're
going to set that thing in there get
some more underlayment in and we're
going to start rocking this pond
at the same time we are going to start
attaching the skimmer
underlayment going
build a ponde everybody networking
[Music]
ah so there's the pod father and we've
got everybody following over so what are
we going to see guys that's an alligator
what drink get eaten okay so they said
you gotta feed the allergy
crocodile so i'm gonna go feed a
crocodile right now so this could get
interesting
[Music]
wow
yes
[Music]
here
hey great job everybody
it's been an incredible couple of days
yes and right here is our new feature
super proud of the guys for creating
this look at how great that is
isn't it fun to be completely think this
is uh it was it was just an incredible
time
so many new faces a lot of new faces a
lot of people finding us on the youtube
vlogs and everything else
so listen if you guys want to be part of
this go to aquascapeinc.com we'll put a
link down below in this video and you
can see what the next opportunity for a
hands-on training event is everywhere in
the country because we're going to be
coming to you
and if not just check out the aquascape
university but for me to be able to do
this it's just like the old times build
upon this you've been doing this since
and we're going to keep doing them maybe
in your area or you just fly and come to
whatever area we're in good job chris
thanks buddy all right isn't it insane
what a small army of newbies
to aquascape and aquascape ecosystem
ponds can create
a huge shout out and thank you to tim
wood jay duke
pete donahue brian rosen john adams
april dugan
and so many many many more people but
also all the new people for
coming out and being a part of this
we're gonna get out of here we're gonna
go check out what ed
is doing and go check out that advanced
build
[Music]
holy cow we are back we've got the man
to make the legend of course ed the pond
professor
fast forward about two weeks since we
kind of hard stop
out here right yep ed's wearing his
green shirt for the winter retreat which
signifies that we may have had a group
photo which usually
is the end of a project and we're also
standing in front of the gila monster
shed and there used to be 35 pounds of
stone
30 pounds of stone and it's been changed
over to brick because there's gonna be a
patio going in soon because
the pond is done the pond is done 100
done and it looks
awesome i can't wait i have
i have i've i've taken a little glimpse
of it but we're gonna show you so ed i'm
gonna follow you
let's go baby all right so ed
everything went smooth right everything
went great and that was because we spent
a lot of time in the beginning you and i
have been doing this a long time
we know the benchmarks we know where we
need to be so we made sure we had to get
all those different things completed
the big challenge we had if you remember
was putting in that under drain
all that groundwater coming in causing
problems edges collapsing down
we had to manipulate everything to make
it work and
it came together because once we got all
that infrastructure in place we were
able to focus
on the beauty and this is what we got oh
my god
are you kidding me fine i know right it
was awesome so
we killed it the team that we had out
here master cac certified aquascape
contractors coming in from around the
country
coming together working as a team which
is what i love because we were able to
split up into multiple groups
what we did i spent the time in the very
beginning laid everything out
gave them the background of what you and
i did here two weeks ago
showed them all of that stuff and then
we started tackling everything we hit
the intake bay we finished up that
beautiful little southwestern arroyo
which is going behind that that cypress
stump we put in those big logs
we got that wetland finish we did the
waterfalls we did all that detail work
the edging the plants the lights
and graded everything but it's still not
a 100 finish because there's a massive
structure going over the entire top of
this
and they are starting on monday so there
is no time there's no rest in this the
brick is here
patio's going in next footers are going
in place this is going to be covered
john and jen are gonna start planting
this up with that beautiful southwestern
look which is just gonna be incredible i
cannot wait to come back here in about a
year
to check this one out awesome awesome
awesome eddie thanks brother
go get a cold one thanks thank you all
right so that was awesome to get kind of
the intro from ed if you remember when
we last left off
we had about 85 90 of this rocked
and we had a couple frame rocks in the
wetland dry fitted and installed
all we needed to do is beautify it over
here we've got the
intake bay area these are those external
pumps that we talked about so we've got
an 18 000 gallon per hour pump and a 12
000 gallon per hour pump
drawing in 30 000 gallons per hour
feeding
that amazing looking waterfalls and
wetland filter
as well as the circulation jets that are
along this back side and down at the
bottom that we talked about remember
those steps that we put in once that
water clears up you'll be able to see
but this goes down into here then there
then there then there making this very
very approachable and interactive
what i love and i mean love is the shape
of the pond i love these peninsulas
we managed to really capitalize on the
square footage that was in here
and we just took over and made an
incredible space for john and jen to
relax get in but also enjoy we've got
the little seating area over here
there's april what up april
april was instrumental in helping myself
oh wait wait wait there he is
come here what do you think i love it
man shawn and i have known each other
for
eight years now and i gotta tell you
he's one of my best homies
in the industry and there's a lot what i
know and have not been able to do in the
past and what you guys have seen our
videos for this guy right here so
he is jason's brother he is a very
valuable member of earthworks and
without
him this all wouldn't have happened so
he's a fantastic guy i just wanted you
guys to see
face with the name that we were talking
about earlier in the video so thanks bro
thank you
you did a great job thank you sir you're
the man so anyways we've got the intake
bay
we've got this straight down section
that we talked about where we're gonna
bring the patio up out over
you can see all these big craggy rocks
these peninsulas the incredible shape of
this pond
really making it organic and interactive
now that you guys can see where water
level actually is in the pond you can
see that big cypress log
that dives down into the water the way
we intended it you've got that large
cavity where it's hollowed out great
place for carnivorous plants
but it just really changes the shape
we've got this aquatic planetary behind
it with this gravel beach
avalanche landslide but guys girls
everybody alike
look at these waterfalls now if you
remember it was just
that rock that rock that rock and that
rock
we only set this stuff and then we dug
out the wetland filter
filled it got all the gravel and
substrate in but we didn't do any of the
beautiful stuff on top and the guys did
a fantastic
the guys did a fantastic job of pulling
it off creating that vision i know when
we were out here the last time we had
talked about splitting the waterfalls
back behind this triangle rock getting a
little kicker over there big waterfalls
and then just a
like a nice raging ripple effect a lot
of white water
this looks incredible absolutely
incredible i love the change in
direction
it just turned out outstanding the edge
work is incredible
guys look at all that open water
if you remember the amount of energy and
effort it took to get down to that four
and a half foot depth
was a lot you can't even see the
architectural wall right now because the
water's a little murky and that's okay
that will all settle out but it turned
out beautiful that's the biological
filter right up in there
everybody so that's that wetland filter
so that upper pooling area with that
enormous log along the back edge there's
a log here
just the incorporation of these wood
elements is so crucial in helping make
this thing look
natural and organic and then of course
you've got the main waterfalls dumping
into that upper pool which is the
wetland filter
everything looks outstanding i can't
wait as ed said for that lanai to get
built
and really see this thing totally come
to fruition when the patio is in where
i'm standing
the walkway everything over there and
then the landscape i know john and jen
are going to take extremely good care of
this i know they have great vision
because we've seen what john
and jen have been able to do over at the
alligator farm so they definitely have
their work cut out for them but i know
they're up to the challenge guys this is
an incredible water feature it's been an
incredible journey
i was so proud happy to be a part of the
prep work i wish i could have been here
for this but on the same token i was
glad to be bringing some new people
into the aquascape lifestyle helping
coach them on how to build build water
features that are going to bring
enjoyment to everybody else's life till
next time we'll see you later
[Applause]
[Music]
high
you